merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires le 22
novembre monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé la mise en place d'un temps de
formation et de sensibilisation à
destination des élus locaux sur les
questions de transition écologique le
groupe modem est indépendant salut cette
mesure les collectivités locales étant
en première ligne pour engager les
chantiers pour accélérer la transition
écologique selon vos annonces les
agences du ministère à l'instar de Météo
France de l'ADEME ou de l'EFB seraient
chargé de ses formations ma première
question est simple monsieur le ministre
quels moyens et quelles ressource
humaine pourrait être allouée à ses
agences pour remplir cette mission
concernant l'objet de ces formations
vous avez annoncé je vous cite qu'il
s'agissait de regarder territoire par
territoire ce que sont déjà les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
et la manière dont on peut prendre des
mesures pour l'atténuer et s'y adapter
si nos élus locaux sont déjà au fait de
l'impact des changements climatiques il
apparaît en revanche qu'il rencontre de
véritables difficultés pour app les
enjolies au développement des énergies
renouvelables et de la ressource en eau
vulgarisation des enjeux de l'énergie
contraintes urbanistiques réglementation
connaissance des différentes solutions
techniques intégration des ENR au réseau
et financement sont par exemple autant
de sujets qui sont cruciaux à ce titre
il me semblerait important que les
volets développement des EnR et gestion
de l'eau soient intégrée à ces
formations avec un accompagnement
particulier sur ces sujets par des
formateurs dédiés il ne s'agit pas
évidemment de faire de nos élus locaux
des techniciens ou des ingénieurs mais
bien de leur donner les clés pour éviter
de tomber dans certains écueils et pour
s'assurer en amont de la réussite des
projets qu'il pourrait développer enfin
concernant le financement de ces
formations monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser le ciel
viendront émarger ou non sur l'enveloppe
de 2 milliards d'euros alloués au fond
vert je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]